[Music]
see you so excited you got him locked
down you moving like I did before I
found
out just a pretty face darker good with
his money Clos to his mother you see
whated you got her right now she be like
he's so perfect I'll be like a person
about got me nervous baby I've been
there right sleep so baby don't get this
disted nothing going make me miss
it it's okay I'm okay H I'm in the first
place it's okay I'm okay it's okay I'm
okay I don't really got to say it's okay
you can have them
anyway anyway you can have them
anyway
anyway what such a Roman
you got me like that some
on now I can go near that she be like
he's so perfect I'll be like I'm nobody
got me nervous baby I been
there baby don't get this nothing going
make me miss it yours it's okay I'm okay
hit him in the first place it's okay I'm
okay it's okay I'm okay I don't really
got to say it's okay okay you can have
them
anyway anyway you can have them
anyway
any it's okay I'm okay I'm in the first
place it's okay I'm okay it's okay I'm
okay I don't really got to say it's okay
you can have him
anyway anyway you can have
anyway
any I don't any girl take I
don't girl take I
[Music]
don't
don't girl take I
don't girl take I don't okay it's okay
take I
don't I don't
[Music]
hey there friends I hope you enjoyed
that flow session uh I have seen most of
the dancers that I like following online
work with that song in the past few
weeks so of course I was very very eager
to give it my own spin pun intended and
speaking of things that spin if you
would like to get yourself into a set of
those orb po Pros that I was using in
this video you can do so by using the
promo code Drex factor with a zero
instead of an O at checkout over at
ultra.com that'll get you a discount of
10% on any item in their online store
once again that is Drex factor with a
zero instead of an O uh thank you so
much to ultra poy for sponsoring this
video and giving me a reason to go out
and play around with some cool songs and
some cool places uh speaking of thank
yous I also owe a thank you to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys pyroar light toys and Ultra poy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- buus friend of the channel That is
Becca Becken thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission kto Pon uh also this video and
all the videos on this channel would not
exist without my amazing supporters on
patreon in particular I'd love to give a
shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now thank you so
much you all rock and if you out there
watching are not currently a supporter
but you like the content that I create
and you'd like to see me make more of it
the best way to help me do that is to to
head on over to my patreon at
patreon.com Factor poy and sign up to
support my work not only will you get
access to some pretty awesome rewards
but also you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you finally if
you want to see more of these flow
sessions of mine I will go ahead and
include a link to a playlist of those
videos down in the description as well
as up on screen thank you so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
today and if you live in the United
States Happy Thanksgiving eat lots of
turkey for me thanks so much and I'll
see you soon in the new video peace